bonsoir nous sommes avenue gustave
eiffel à dijon et nous partons à la
rencontre de familles qui ont vu leur
vie basculer lorsque leurs proches ont
été tués dans l'explosion de leur
immeuble
à quelques mètres de là c'était le 4
décembre 1999
souvenez-vous à 23h45 une violente
explosion se produit au 145 de l'avenue
eiffel à dijon
l'ensemble du bloc 1 d'un immeuble de
cinq étages s'effondrent les secours
vont fouiller les décombres pendant
toute la nuit et le jour suivant
le bilan est dramatique les pompiers
retrouvons les corps sans vie de 11
personnes six femmes trois hommes et
deux enfants
l' enquête démontrera que cette
explosion la plus grave qu'ait connue
dijon a été provoqué par la rupture
d'une canalisation de gaz en fonte grise
un matériau qui a été interdite depuis
par arrêté ministériel en 2005
ce drame a fait basculer la vie de la
famille chaudron autour de la table il
manque une fille et une soeur julie 20
ans tué dans l'explosion à quelque chose
qui a changé en nous et on le voit on le
on peu après sans apercevoir dans les
réactions qu'on peut avoir du quotidien
de la vie mais russe c'est les autres
qui s'en aperçoive
pour nous il y eu des moments j'avais
l'impression de sentir la mort
simplement depuis la mort et puis que
les gens avaient un peu peur de moi en
face on écartait j'ai vu des amis me
regarder
j'avais déjà l'impression dans leur
regard d'un d'être d'être une bête
bizarre et un certain sentiment de
culpabilité aussi après que peu de bt
survivant là parce que normalement il
aurait dû partir avec elle est mieux
bon ça ça a été aussi douleur à
supporter un autre douleur celle du
procès qui a impacté les familles des
parents qui passait des heures sur
internet pour faire avancer l'enquêté du
temps qu'ils n'ont pas pu accorder à
leurs autres enfants mais qui a payé
il ya eu quand même bien que ça soit
très lent il ya des évolutions dans la
cartographie des 0d et des réseaux la
législation les échanges même si tout
n'est pas parfait à quand il ya une
explosion est allé prise en charge les
cellules psychologiques
au début il ya des choses qu'ils ont
paru si t'es pas complet c'est de mieux
en mieux ça se structure françoise
bonnet a perdu son fils arnaud le soir
du drame il fêtait ses 18 ans entre
copains c'est arnaud égal à lui même
toujours en train de faire l'idiot un
mariage françoise a choisi de ne pas
nous rencontrer à son domicile
je ne serai pas exprimé la même façon
devant mon mari parce que même dans un
couple chaque peine différente on n'en
parle pas de la même façon
moi j'ai besoin d'en parler tout en tout
temps un besoin qui n'était alors pas
partagée par son entourage et qui a
contribué à isoler françoise c'est le
désert total quoi à part notre vie d'un
nombre plus personne du tout alors bon
on a la chance qu'on a deux copains
d'arnaud extraordinaire qui eux ne nous
ont jamais lâcher du début et qui
viennent régulièrement et pour nous mais
c'est ça souffle d'air c'est incroyable
quoi seul dans sa détresse françoise
mère d'une autre enfant de 12 ans à
l'époque était en proie à des pensées
suicidaires
je me suis mais tu es fan quoi tu allais
toi même abandonner ainsi à nouveau ne
put tire-t-on route de merde t'as déjà
du mal à tenir
donc est ce qu'elle mange le toute
discussion est quasi impossible
c'est sur internet qu'elle a trouvé du
soutien et un réseau à qui elle apporte
désormais son est aidée c'est ce qui a
porté sylvie forest le 4 décembre 99 sa
famille a perdu fanny 19 ans elle a
alors créé un groupe de parole à la
maison des associations où nous nous
sommes rencontrés la porte parole ce pas
c'est pas évident parce que il faut se
dire que moi c'est ce que je disais
toujours aux familles sains disait voilà
on se barre mais on n'est pas sûr du
résultat
c'était un peu linéaire poursuivi
fallait la gagner quand leur marche on
n'aura pas beaucoup
oui mais comme disait le président du
tunnel du mont blanc c'est pareil les
amphis puisque c'est le tunnel du mont
blanc s'était aussi citer rita et un
comme ils disaient ils disaient que tout
ça nous maintenaient quand même à flot
nous on se battait pas du tout pour des
indemnités
on se battait vraiment pour de la
prévention quoi ce qui a été terrible
pour nous c'est qu'en 2004 à strasbourg
n'y ait eu de nouveaux 18 morts alors
qu'on avait frappé à toutes les portes
quoi sert le roux malheur c'est
monstrueux du coup on est parti en 2004
on vit dans le midi maintenant moi je
supporte plus les dents tout dans mon
d'andijan entre la morgue les écoles la
maternelle et 20 ou quoi de toute façon
que les années passent plus
plus la douleur est forte c'est à dire
que vous avez cette sorte de de dia
ainsi à tromelin pas par exemple d'avoir
39 ans à ce qu'elles auraient des
enfants à ce qu elle serait mariée quel
métier lauret et vous reste toujours des
enfants c'est mais je veux dire à mon là
le goût de revivre revient avec
les petits enfants les familles se
réuniront le 4 décembre prochain pour un
dernier hommage collectif à leurs
proches